[Music]
let's look at AWS marketplace AWS
marketplace is an online store where you
can buy software that runs on Amazon Web
Services we've gone through a lot of
services and you must be wondering where
do I get help where do I buy some
software that integrates with all these
services AWS marketplace is the buying
and selling platform where you can
either buy or sell software that
integrate with AWS services they are
open source commercial these are for
businesses enterprises and they're also
for developers and they are available in
a range of categories such as OS
security networking storage business
intelligence DevOps
databases monitoring logging etc
so let's take a look at AWS marketplace
so once you come over here you can see
that you will have something called AMI
that is a machine image and you can also
have something for software as-a-service
let's look at the DevOps most of these
are offered as a free trial as well and
if you want to see just the free
versions you can click on the pricing
plan and then you can see that you get
these images of software of Amazon
machine image the AMI and you can just
install it on your hardware that you
provision from AWS and that is how you
start using these things and as you can
see here there are a lot of developers
tools infrastructure business software
if you want to make some dashboards if
you want to run some analytics you can
do many of those things and more
right over here so come over here
explore the things you want to do
whether it's security databases
networking or anything else you might be
looking for hey want to become an expert
in cloud computing then subscribe to
simpler channel and click here to watch
more such videos turner it up and get
certified in cloud computing click here